o no
[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy vamos a empezar con algunos
nombres
regina martínez rubén espinoza jesús
adrián rodríguez javier arturo valdez
miroslava breach y así podríamos
continuar hasta 119 el número de
periodistas asesinados en méxico desde
el año 2000 por estar investigando casos
de narcotráfico o corrupción méxico se
ha convertido sin duda en uno de los
países más peligrosos para los
periodistas y para hablarnos de todo
ello hoy hace escala en parís
paloma tripón dedines aunque es de la
red internacional de periodistas de
investigación coordinados por forbidden
stories paloma muchísimas gracias y
bienvenida gracias buenos días desde
fortín stories están coordinando una
macro investigación que se llama
proyecto cartel en qué consiste
mira el proyecto cartel son 60
periodistas de 25 medios en el mundo del
'washington post' de lumen de proceso en
mexico
y lo que hicimos es retomar y seguir con
el trabajo de la periodista asesinada
mexicana
regina martínez y rastrear los carteles
mexicanos en el mundo
es una multinacional del crimen ya una
multinacional del crimen se le tiene que
investigar de una forma global y con una
respuesta global y poniendo todos los
esfuerzos colaborativos posibles
justamente como están investigando cómo
se organizan y con qué fuentes cuentan
mira lo que es interesante en eso es que
hace pocos años un periodista por dar
una información a otro periodista lo
podían echar y aquí nosotros es
completamente lo contrario la idea es
que es que uno dice mira yo tengo tal
fuente en la inteligencia americana y
otro periodista dice ah yo tengo en la
inteligencia mexicana y lo que hacemos y
lo que hemos hecho es como que cada uno
aporta sus fuentes y dice mira yo tengo
tantas personas que pueden hablar del
tema
hacemos como un esfuerzo global para ir
lo más lejos posibles en las pistas que
estaba investigando
regina martínez a través de la
investigación que están llevando a cabo
me gustaría preguntarle cuál es el
peligro para un periodista mexicano qué
temas concretos lo ponen en peligro el
el tema que más pone en peligro a los
periodistas mexicanos es el tema de la
narcopolítica que son los vínculos entre
los políticos y los grupos criminales y
este es el tema que pone en peligro a
los periodistas mexicanos y es muy
importante recordar que los periodistas
que más están en peligro son los
periodistas locales y regina martínez
justamente es un caso emblemático de
ello estaba investigando estos vínculos
y pero era la primera periodista
nacional en méxico que fue asesinada y
entonces el mensaje era muy fuerte
porque el mensaje era sí sí matan a
regina martínez pueden matar a
cualquiera y entonces esto es lo que
hace que este caso fue tan fuerte y que
queríamos investigar recuerden no sé en
qué circunstancias fue fue asesinada
regina fue en 2012 que estaba
investigando exactamente con quién había
dado no pues regina martínez en
la versión de las autoridades locales es
que es que fue asesinada por un robo
pero la investigación que nosotros
llevamos a cabo nos permitió corroborar
con diferentes fuentes que ella estaba
investigando un tema sobre la
desaparición de personas en veracruz en
las fosas comunes del gobierno de
veracruz con la complicidad de políticos
locales y ya estaba investigando este
tema un tema un año antes de que la
asesinaran y nos a nosotros nos parecía
muy importante como revelarlo al público
por el deber de informarnos sobre que
ella trabajaba y por qué las autoridades
locales no no querían o no quieren que
se sepa la verdad
en una fuente que podéis ver en el
documental justamente de que salió en el
hosting realizado por porción llegó da
en esta en este documental hablamos con
una fuente del interior del gobierno de
veracruz y que dice a ningún gobierno le
gusta que le destape en la cloaca y la
idea es realmente que el tema de los
desaparecidos es algo muy muy fuerte y
sobre todo en unos años ahora es un tema
que ya ha salido pero es simplemente
desde el 2016 cuando regina estaba
investigando el tema de los
desaparecidos nadie hablaba de este tema
los los familiares de desaparecidos
pensaban encontrar sus familiares vivos
en alguna parte pero no tenía ni idea
que estaban escondidos en la misma en la
misma fosa común del estado adán quezada
para el estado allí delante
en el caso de regiones emblemático como
dice para entender el problema de la
narcopolítica y para entender como
decíamos que no es un problema solo
mexicano sino que es un problema global
y las investigaciones en ese caso les
han llevado a encontrar ramificaciones
no fuera de las fronteras mexicanas es
el caso de los lleva incluso hasta
barcelona
qué pasa cuál es la conexión entre
veracruz regina barcelona es muy
importante eso que que lo tengamos en
mente que cuando se muere un periodista
mexicano es una historia que nos toca a
nosotros también porque cuando por
ejemplo javier valdez está investigando
el cartel de sinaloa el cártel de
sinaloa vende drogas a 57 países en el
mundo entonces también por eso nosotros
luego vamos a investigar las
ramificaciones y en el caso de barcelona
el tema que vincula es que el gobernador
de veracruz que regina estaba
investigando y que pensaba ella que
estaba en vínculo
con estas desapariciones de personas con
cómplice
fue nombrado cónsul y fue nombrado
cónsul en barcelona- y gracias a un
periodista del consorcio que está basado
en barcelona nos pudimos cuenta que allá
también había sido objeto de
investigaciones y depresión asuntos
vínculos con
con el narco local y el grupo george
o'dowd o beach y pudimos ver que hasta
ahora este hombre sigue completamente
impune y nunca enfrentó ningún tipo de
justicia o sea porque aquí ya no estamos
hablando de que los poderes públicos
pueden ser cómplices o actúan porque
tienen
[Música]
la espada de damocles de encima del
grupos de narcotraficantes locales
estamos hablando de que son responsables
son sus investigaciones que son
responsables exactamente es es qué
la particularidad de que ya no se separa
mucho la frontera entre quien es
político y quienes narco en una zona
como por ejemplo veracruz y investigar
esto es es particularmente sensible y
sobre todo a nivel local ahora lo que
nos decía la gente cuando estábamos en
el terreno es que en vez de decir los
zetas por ejemplo van a decir un grupo
criminal mató a la autocensura ya está
muy integrada pero porque es una forma
de sobrevivencia y nosotros que tenemos
la posibilidad de hablar libremente es
pues es un deber hacerlo hay por ejemplo
otro caso no muy importante el del
asesinato de miroslava breach las
autoridades crean que esa investigación
fuera como un modelo no pero la
investigación para ti no completamente
no se llegó al fondo justamente por la
narcopolítica en el estado de chihuahua
y hay muchas pistas casi muy evidentes
para investigar que no se investigaron y
no se respondió a preguntas claves no
sobre cuál era el vínculo con los grupos
políticos
y los grupos delictivos
porque la mataron o sea es como una
especie de si vamos a hacer una
investigación finalmente no vamos a
responder a nada de lo importante claro
es que como en el 99 99% de los casos de
periodistas asesinados hay total
impunidad y en el caso de miroslava
breach y de regina martínez muestran lo
mismo no que no hay una voluntad
política de dar con de investigar como
línea de investigación interesarse en el
trabajo periodístico que estaban
llevando a cabo entonces es una línea
que muy rápidamente se pone de lado y lo
que se va a investigar es a los que
ejecutaron el crimen y se van a incluso
a encontrar montajes como en el caso de
regina martínez que recuerdo que
nosotros hemos identificado en la
investigación del cartel project confort
biden souris
se crearon 180 cuentas boots que son
falsas cuentas twitter que se publicaban
masivamente la versión oficial del
gobierno de veracruz que era que el la
muerte de de regina era consecuencia de
un robo entonces eso es
el problema de la justicia a la
veracruzana como sea es que desvinculan
completamente digamos el asesinato del
tema de la investigación que estaban
llevando a cabo intentan hacer pasar por
un crimen común no los exactamente no se
interesan en el trabajo periodístico y
entonces nosotros lo que hacemos es como
darle una segunda voz y saber que estos
periodistas escribiendo sabían que una
nota los podía y podía hacer que
costarles la vida entonces nosotros
pensamos que podemos cómo hacer
sobrevivir este este mensaje y la idea
es como no matarán o matarán al
periodista pero no matarán a su mensaje
no mandarán la investigación que ustedes
intentan seguir
justamente cuáles son las dificultades
que encuentran ustedes a la hora de
investigar y qué riesgos corren ustedes
porque también van al terreno yo creo
que ahí es muy importante decir que
los que corren riesgos son los
periodistas locales que nosotros tenemos
unos protocolos muy importantes y que
vamos como de pasada no tres días aquí
está todo muy organizado y no tenemos
los niños en la escuela que van a ir a
amenazar no no tenemos nuestros hijos en
la escuela y en realidad yo creo que
sobre todo el peligro está para las
fuentes que nosotros vamos a entrevistar
y que luego se quedan y creo que es eso
que es muy importante poner de relieve y
en el caso de de bueno obviamente hay
hay ahí hay peligro pero el peligro está
sobre todo en los pasajes tienen los
otros dos colores de seguridad muy
importantes para proteger a los
periodistas locales ya las fuentes para
proteger a las fuentes no encontrarlas
por ejemplo en su casa a veces que una
fuente se desplace a otro lugar porque
hay un hay un lugar en el que podríamos
ser vistos
a lo mejor no verse así si es que es
demasiado peligroso
si siempre pensar en la persona que se
queda bueno pues muchísimas gracias
paloma dupont edición de la red
internacional de periodistas de
investigación coordinados por forbidden
stories y que están llevando a cabo el
proyecto cartel sobre estos periodistas
asesinados en méxico y que continúan sus
investigaciones y le deseamos mucha
suerte con este trabajo y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir por internet en rf y mundo.com y
en france24 punto com hasta afrontan 2
[Música]